GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So this is the next step for
a first-order differential
equation.
We take-- instead
of an exponential,
now we have an oscillating.
Exponentials, the previous
lecture, grew or decayed,
now we have an oscillate.
We have AC, alternating
current in this problem,
instead of real exponentials,
we have oscillation, vibration,
all the applications that
involve circular motion,
going around and around instead
of going off exponentially.
OK.
So here's the point.
Again I'm looking for
a particular solution.
The particular solution--
it would be nice
if we could say the
particular solution
was just some multiple
of the cosine.
But that won't work.
So that makes this
problem one step harder
than the exponential.
We need to allow
the signs in there.
Because, if I look for a cosine,
if I tried only this part,
I could match that.
I'd have a times the cosine,
that would be cosine.
But the derivative of a
cosine is a sine function.
So signs are going
to get in there
and we have to allow
them into the solution.
OK.
So that's the right
thing to assume.
Actually there will
be, you'll see,
three different ways to write
the answer to this problem.
And this is the first sort
of most straightforward,
but not the best
in the long run.
OK.
Straightforward one, I'm
going to substitute that
into the equation and find
M and N. That's my job.
Find these numbers.
So put that into the equation.
On the left side I
want the derivative,
so that we'll be omega--
well derivative of the cosine
is minus omega m sine omega t.
The derivative brought
out this factor omega.
The derivative of
cosine was sine.
Now the derivative
of this brings out
a factor of omega--
omega N cosine omega t.
And that should equal
a times y-- there's y,
so I just multiply by
a-- a M cosine omega t,
and a N sine omega t.
That's the ay part.
And now I have the source
term plus cosine omega t.
And that has to be
true for all time.
And now I need the equation.
What do I do with this?
I'm looking for two
things, M and N.
I'm looking for two equations.
So I match the cosine terms.
I match that term, that cosine
term, and the source term.
So they all multiply
cosine omega t.
So I want omega
n-- so I bring this
over on the other side--
minus a m plus omega n
equals-- here I just have
one cosine-- equals 1.
Minus a M plus omega N equals 1.
And now I'll match
the sine terms.
So in the sine terms, I have
a minus omega M, sine omega t.
And I have to bring
this on the other side,
so that'll be a minus
a N sine omega t.
And there's no sine
omega t in the source.
There's my two equations.
Those are my two
equations for M and N.
So I just solve
those two equations
and I've got the particular
solution that I look for.
So, it's two equations,
two unknowns.
It's the basic problem
of linear algebra.
I'm inclined to just write
down the answer, which
I prepared in advance.
And it turns out
to be minus a over
omega squared plus a squared.
And N turns out to have
that same omega squared
plus a squared, and
above it goes omega.
If you check this equation,
for example, omega times the M
will give me a a omega
with a minus with a minus.
And then a times N will
also have an a omega.
And the same omega
squared plus a
squared, they cancel to give 0.
And this equation
is also solved.
So one more important
problem solved.
Well, we found the
particular solution.
I haven't added in-- I haven't
match the initial condition.
Now in many, many cases,
it's this particular solution
that's of interest.
This here-- let me put a
box around our solution--
and we substituted that in
the differential equation.
We discovered M. We
discovered N. We've
got this particular solution.
And that's the oscillation
that keeps going.
That if we're listening
to radio or if we
have alternating current,
this is what we see,
the null solution.
The thing that's coming
with no source term.
Usually a is negative
and that disappears.
That's called the
transient term.
So the null solution would be
have an ae to the at as always.
But I'm not so interested in
that because it disappears.
You don't hear it
after a minute.
And this is the solution that
you're-- this is what your ear
is hearing.
OK.
So we've got one
form of the answer.
Now, that's a pretty nice
form, but it's not perfect.
I can't see exactly--
this can be simplified
in a really nice way.
So when we work with
sines and cosines,
it's this next step
that's important.
I believe that that
same yp of t can
be written in a different
way as what also--
another form, a different--
well I should say,
another form for
the same y of t.
Another form will
be the same y of t.
You see what I don't like is
having a cosine and a sine
because those are out of
phase, and they're combining it
into something, and
I want to find out
what their combining into.
And it's really nice.
They're combining into a single
cosine, but not just omega t,
there's a lag, a phase shift.
The angle involved is
often called the phase.
So the two, sine
and cosine, combine
to give a phase shift
with some amplitude,
maybe I'll call it G, the gain.
Or often it would be
called capital R just
for-- because it's-- sort of
what you're seeing here is
polar coordinates.
So I want to match
this, which has the G
and the alpha-- polar
coordinates is really
the right way to think of this.
G and an alpha, a
magnitude and an angle.
I want to match that with
the form I already had.
So I'll use a little
trigonometry here
to remember that
this is equal to-- I
have a G. Do you
remember a formula
for the cosine of a minus b?
The cosine of a difference
is cosine of omega t,
cosine of alpha,
plus-- it's a plus
here because it's
a minus there--
sine omega t sine alpha.
So I have just written this
out in the two-term form,
and I did that so that I could
match the two-term form I
already had.
So can I just do that matching?
The cosine omega t, the
M must be G cosine alpha.
And they N must be G sine alpha.
So I now have two equations.
The M and the N, I still
remember what those are.
I figured those out.
But now I want to convert the
M N form to the G alpha form,
and this is what I have to do.
And it's the usual thing
with polar coordinates.
How can I get-- how do I
discover what G is there,
and what alpha is?
The trick is-- the one
fundamental identity
when you see cosines and sines--
is to remember that cosine
squared plus sine squared is 1.
I'm going to use
that, have to use it.
So I'll square both sides.
I'll have M squared,
and I'll add.
So I'll have M squared
plus N squared is
G squared cosine squared alpha.
G squared times
cosine squared alpha--
when I square that one--
and sine squared alpha
when I square that one.
And again, the
point is that's one.
So that's just G squared.
So what do I learned?
G is the square root of this.
G is the square root of
M squared plus N squared.
And I'm always freedom plug-in
the M and the N that I found.
OK that's-- ah,
what about alpha?
That's the angle.
So I have to-- again,
I'm thinking trig here.
How am I going to
get alpha here?
I want to get G
out of this formula
now, and just
focus on the alpha.
Previously I got alpha
out of it and got the G.
Now the way to do
is take the ratio.
If I take the ratio
of that to that,
divide one by the other,
the G's will cancel.
So I'll take the
ratio of that to that
to get G sine alpha divided by
g cosine alpha is then N over M.
And the G's cancel as I wanted.
So now I have an
equation for alpha.
Or more exactly, I have an
equation for tangent of alpha.
Sine over cosine is tangent
of alpha is N over M.
So this is called
the-- you could call it
the sinusoidal identity.
What is that word sinusoid?
Sinusoid is a word for any
mixture of sines and cosines,
any mixture of sines and
cosines of the same omega t.
So the sinusoidal
identity says that I
can rewrite that solution
into this solution.
And I really see the key
number in the whole thing
is the gain, the magnitude.
It's how loud the
station comes through
if we're tuning a radio.
So and again, this
is the response
that's keeps going because
the cosine oscillates forever.
There will be also
something coming
from the initial condition
that we expect to die out.
So I mentioned at the
very start that there
were three forms of the
answer to this cosine input,
and I've given you two.
I've given you the M and N form.
You could say rectangular
coordinates-- cosines
and sines.
I've given you the
polar form, which
is a gain, a
magnitude, and a phase.
And the third one
involves complex numbers.
I have to make that a separate
lecture, maybe even two.
So complex numbers,
where do they come in?
It's a totally real equation.
If I think about all
this that I've done,
it was all totally
real, but there's
a link-- the key fact about
complex numbers, Euler's
great formula will give me a
connection between cosine omega
t and sine omega t with
e to the I omega t.
So at the price of introducing
that complex number,
imaginary number i, or j
for electrical engineers,
we're back to exponentials.
We're back to exponentials.
So that'll come in
the next lecture.
This is one more example
of a nice source function.
Maybe I could just say, what
are the nicest source functions?
So this is the source
function here and it was nice.
Exponential was even nicer.
Constant was best of all.
And I want to-- another
one I want to introduce
is a delta function.
So that's-- a delta
function is an impulse,
something that
happens in an instant.
And that's an interesting, very
interesting and very important
possibility.
OK.
Thank you.